hello contender welcome to the hyper
scape our nil fast-paced Battle Royale
that brings verticality to the next
level in hyper scape up to 100 players
will compete in a variety of game modes
squad and solo cram rush are the main
modes where battle royale champions are
crowned neo Arcadia is a virtual
shimmering city designed to encourage
vertical mobility and fast-paced combat
situations from sky-high towers to
deadly interiors you will constantly
need to adapt your fighting styles
once the battle begins your personalized
deployment pod is your transport to the
battle you will be able to drop in any
part of the map so pick your drop spot
wisely hit the ground running because
you'll start with only a melee weapon
hotly contested landmarks are known to
contain abundant caches of gear but high
risk brings the chance of high reward
gear is found inside buildings closed
off by breakable barricades and inside
supply crates located around the map
as you traverse the city looking for
gear and enemies you'll discover the
different environments create diverse
gameplay opportunities and challenges
your competition may come from any angle
every battle in hyperscale is a fresh
experience where you leverage the varied
arsenal you will find in neo arcadia
your loadout is not determined by the
character you choose but by the weapons
and hacks you loot from full auto
assault weapons to powerful energy
plasters there is a tool for any play
style hacks are game-changing abilities
you mute around the map that grants
skills for offense defense and movement
or you can lead to weapons and to hacks
and swap them at any time
if you need to change your strategy the
choice is in your hands if you find a
copy of a weapon or hack you already
have in your possession you can fuse it
creating an upgraded version each eye
can be upgraded several levels improving
magazine size damage or cooldown
duration
as you discover your footing in the
hyper scape your squad will be there to
help you use the ping system to sync
with your squad and warn them of
potential threats or alert them to
potential resources if an enemy manages
to take you out the battle is not over
at zero health you'll become an echo and
you can help your squad by scouting
ahead when enemies are eliminated a
restore point appears in that spot
finder restore point and your squad
mates can bring you back into the fight
as your game master one of my favorite
tasks is to keep things lively by
triggering battle events such as the
infinite ammo event or the low gravity
event viewers on Twitch helped influence
my choice and can vote on additional
events so remember to play the crowd
keep an eye on your map contender as the
match progresses sectors will decay and
collapse throughout neo Arcadia if
you're too late reaching a safe area you
will take damage over time and may be
exposed to enemy attacks
those skilled enough will enter the
showdown phase the hyper scape crown
will spawn in the final remaining sector
from here you have two different paths
to victory become the sole survivors or
hold on to the crown for forty-five
seconds you are now prepared for the
hyper scape contender
we here at prisoner dimensions hope you
enjoy your stay